avril 1904
un champion
france de natation finale du 100 m
brasse messieurs qualificatives aux jeux
olympiques je suis à la ligne 6 chacun
monde sur son plot de départ
à vos marques hop c'est parti un
plongeon une coulée je nage vite nage
très vite
à mi course je passe largement en tête
un virage une coulée et jacques centimes
en avance sur la deuxième moitié
je touche premier avec huit dixièmes
d'avancé sur le deuxième c'est un
gouffre à ce niveau là et puis je
regarde le tableau d'affichage pour voir
mon temps et là je suis tellement
surpris non seulement d'être premier
mais de battre le record de france que
j'invente un mot sur le moment fuyu y
et puis moi qui étais si introverti
c'est la première fois de ma vie et
c'est la seule fois de ma carrière que
je lève le bras en direction de mon club
en disant ça y est c'est fait est-ce que
c'était difficile
pas vraiment en fait
dans le premier 50 on est tellement bien
tellement préparé on est tellement
puissant qu'on a juste à ne pas laisser
les chevaux trop libre et puis après la
deuxième moitié effectivement le dernier
quart ça pique ça fait mal on a de la
douleur
on était anisé mais je me suis dit bon
j'ai fait des choses plus difficiles que
ça à l'entraînement et puis je me suis
souvenu qu'il fallait juste nager plus
vite possible jusqu'au mur c'est assez
simple la natation
est-ce que j'étais survoltée on imagine
des gens avant la course survoltée
pas du tout alors là les gens qui me
connaissent savent et que quand
j'arrivais devant une course importante
il m'appelait robocop j'arrivais comme
ça très calme devant le plot j'avais
trouvé une façon d'avoir les pulsations
cardiaques qui montait sans m'agiter et
d'être très focalisé sur la course sans
l'avoir fait quatre fois dans la tête
est ce que j'ai besoin d'une volonté
féroce
mon expérience c'est que j'avais juste à
laisser mon corps faire ce pourquoi je
m'étais entraîné donc j'avais juste à
profiter du plaisir et de l'intensité du
moment en amour c'était très facile
j'étais dans ma zone de confort et je
voudrais vous parler aujourd'hui du fait
qu'on peut réussir des choses
intéressantes en restant dans sa zone de
confort alors clairement on est à
contre-courant de ce qu'on voit dans les
histoires game of thrones ou ailleurs ou
a forcément des drames des cris des gens
qui serre les dents etc et on a
l'impression que c'est la seule façon
que la vie soit intéressante mais est ce
que c'est le cas on peut se parler par
exemple on peut se souvenir j'aimerais
vous rappeler d'un grand accomplissement
que vous avez tous fait ou presque
ce sont nos premiers pas on avait un an
on ne se souvient pas et moi en fait je
me souviens comme si c'était hier
des premiers pas de mon neveu je vous
présente hélios et un jour donc ma soeur
vient avec mon neveu
la porte s'ouvre mon neveu tient la main
de sa mère et pour la première fois je
le vois lâcher la main et il se lance
dans le couloir avec une marche à ses
assurés
il arrive dans le salon sur un tapis il
fait trois tours sur lui-même comme ça
sur un pied pivot et puis s'arrête
ils me regardent comme ça et avec un
énorme sourire et des étoiles plein les
yeux
clairement il vivait une joie intense
mais est ce que l ue s'est dit un jour
bon
maintenant il faut faire sortir de ma
zone de confort sinon je serai jamais un
adulte
il va falloir être un winner veut mettre
sur mes deux pieds
voilà c'est pas ça qui lui est arrivé ce
qui lui est arrivé c'est que ça faisait
un an depuis sa naissance ou
tranquillement il ya un processus qui
est à l'oeuvre
et puis il apprend d'abord à tourner un
peu la tête à orienter son regard et
puis il apprend à savoir qu'un j'ai des
doigts des pieds
et puis je commence à prendre appui et
puis je sais me retourne et puis je sais
commencé à me déplacer librement et au
fur à mesure toutes ces petites
découvertes parfois avec des petites
frustrations il essaye de se retourner
il n'y arrive pas du premier coup mais
avec quelques essais il réussit et
toutes ces petites découvertes se
tissent les unes les autres c'était les
unes les autres et un jour il ya une
compétence qui apparaît nouvelle
dramatique en quelque sorte
il se dit ah je peux marcher sur deux
pieds maintenant il a appris à marcher
tellement bien que il est capable de
faire autre chose et puis il est
qualifié pour les championnats de france
de badminton dans sa catégorie d'âge
bientôt 14 ans et c'est comme ça pour
nous aussi on a fait de nombreux
apprentissages et au fur et à mesure on
apprend à rendre possible des choses qui
semblait impossible alors pour discuter
un petit peu et pour illustrer un petit
peu cette cette chose cette progression
et bien je vous propose une expérience
concrète et pour ça on va utiliser notre
corps et je vais demander donc à une
personne de l'auditoire et à capucine de
me rejoindre sur scène sous vos
applaudissements
bon je connais capucines c'est quoi
votre prénom
jean jé huji donc merci du jet de vous
prêter à l'expérience
donc c'est une expérience qui nous vient
du japon pendant un temps j'ai fait j'ai
eu deux ans au japon je faisais de la
recherche à l'université de kyoto et
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer un
maître d'arts martiaux à l'occasion un
mètre 63 et mes amis rigolait beaucoup
quand je leur envoyais et les vidéos
parce que on avait l'impression que
c'était à ces risques contre les romains
et c'était moi le romain donc il prenait
comme ça et puis y'a un côté voilà et
c'était très joli à voir mais on peut se
poser la question comment il a fait
parce que clairement il était pas ce
n'était pas par la puissance ou je sais
pas quoi il avait il y avait compris
quelque chose et donc on va discuter de
ce petit secret qui nous a confié
pendant un stage je vais demander à john
g moi je vais essayer d'être solide
instable et semble surprendre
il va me pousser par le côté ils
essayent de me faire basculer allons-y
voilà sens utiliser la surprise il n'y a
pas besoin on verra on voit ce qui se
passe on résiste l'un contre l'autre
il se passe pas grand chose là si je me
laisse faire mais si je résiste il se
passe rien
capucine un secret elle connaît le
secret c'est papin ont peut-être c'est
sa puissance incroyable qui est qui est
caché mais elle va faire la même chose
allons-y attention je sais qu'elle est
costaud alors on se dit je me suis
laissé faire
mais peut-être qu'il ya un secret qui
est derrière et pour illustrer ce secret
eh bien on va utiliser un modèle très
simplifiée du squelette
vous reconnaissez debout sur deux lignes
donc le pied droit à droite le pied
gauche à gauche paraît que nous
la plupart des gens quand ils essayent
de faire basculer une personne se
retrouve inconsciemment à pousser vers
le sol
à travers les pieds donc on pousse on
pousse et puis la chaise est tout à fait
capable de résister à cette pression
mais si on s'y prend autrement on
pourrait se dire que ce que je veux
faire c'est faire basculer la chaise et
donc je vais penser à son point d'appui
il y à un point d'appui au dessus duquel
je peux la faire basculer
donc j'ai changé de point de vue et vous
voyez que avec très peu d'énergie
je peux la faire basculer maintenant
john jay fort de ce nouveau secret va me
faire basculer gentiment allons-y donc
maintenant je vais l'inviter à me faire
basculer au dessus de mon pied droit
allons-y donc de me pousser en imaginant
que c'est une baston parce que voilà et
ya rien pour résister à ça à moins que
j'aie main ou un soutien j'ai rien pour
résister à sa merci beaucoup
donc vous voyez que dans cette petite
expérience
ce qu'on constate c'est que en changeant
de point de vue ça devient plus facile
voyez un petit panneau que j'aime bien
et qui illustre un petit peu cette
situation donc vous voyez pouces et si
ça ne marche pas à tirer et puis cela ne
marche pas non plus ça veut dire que le
magasin est fermé
donc on peut se retrouver avec deux
attitudes quand on est devant une porte
fermée
on peut s'énerver mettre plus de force
ça veut dire essayer la même chose plus
fort donc parfois en insultant on a
peut-être une chance mais en général si
ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas
mais inversement ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est s'y prendre autrement
peut-être qu'il y avait un bouton qu'il
fallait appuyer pour déclencher
l'ouverture peut être qu'il fallait s'y
prendre autrement avec la poignée
peut-être que il faut attendre
effectivement que quelqu'un vienne
m'aider parce que il ya une clé donc là
en l'occurrence la question qui va se
poser c'est est ce que c'est vraiment
impossible
ou est ce que c'est juste ma croyance
donc on a deux sortes d'impossible on a
un impossible où on a l'impression qu'il
faut pousser un impossible impossible ce
genre d'un possible c'est ce qui
explique que par exemple même s'il ya
beaucoup de monde dans l'ascenseur
personne ne se dit offre je vais monter
par la façade je vais l'éviter jusqu'au
20ème étage enfin moi je reconnais pas
peut-être vous moi je connais pas ou des
gens qui disent rohff je n'aime pas
faire des créneaux je vais prendre ma
voiture et là posé sur ma place de
stationnement c'est tellement plus
pratique
bon on peut essayer et dans ce genre
d'exemple et bien une personne qui m'est
très cher au japon m'a raconté une
histoire l'histoire d'un petit voisin
américain qui avait huit ans et qui
était c'était un grand fan de superman
il est superman il faisait tout comme
superman
et puis je vous rassure tout de suite il
a survécu mais un jour il a trouvé une
serviette rouge
il se l'est attachée autour du cou et ça
y est l'été superman il est monté dans
un arbre il a sauté il s'est cassé une
jambe voilà donc qu'ils croient qu'ils
étaient super man ou pas ne changeait
pas grand chose par contre dans la
situation où on croit que ce n'est pas
possible mais qu'en fait on n'a pas bien
compris la le système comand comment
faire ben on peut mettre plus d'énergie
et puis là on se dit voilà peut-être
qu'en mettant encore plus d'énergie ça
va marcher mais on perd une occasion de
comprendre comment ça pourrait se passer
plus facilement
on va faire une deuxième expérience
corporelle pour continuer sur ce chemin
et cette fois c'est une expérience qui
vient donc de la fameuse méthode
feldenkrais peut-être c'est la première
fois vous entendez ce nom en tout cas
c'est une pratique corporelle moi qui
m'a énormément appris et dans cette
méthode est bien on apprend à améliorer
des fonctions des fonctionnements et là
je vous propose d'explorer le fait de
regarder à droite et à gauche
vous n'avez peut-être pas vu vos voisins
à droite et à gauche alors pour que tout
le monde soit au même niveau je vous
invite à poser les pieds par terre
si vous avez les gens me croisent et
pour être libre de vos mouvements
et puis regarder jusqu'où est ce que
c'est facile de regarder injustement
observée jusqu'au est-ce que c'est
facile de regarder à droite à gauche
sans forcer l'idée ce n'est pas de
forcer mais de regarder jusqu'aux est-ce
que c'est facile et une option pour
améliorer ça on pourrait vous dire ah
ben il faudrait utiliser ça il faudrait
utiliser ça la plupart d'entre nous on
utilise beaucoup de coups pour faire ça
alors on pourrait vous dire il faut
utiliser je ne sais pas quel vertèbres
moi je vous propose une contrainte ça
veut dire de mettre à contribution votre
intelligence corporelle et cette
contrainte c'est de coller ici l'état
lendemain l'un contre l'autre
et puis là avec le micro je vais pas
pouvoir le faire mais de coller les
mains sur les joues voilà et on a l'air
très faim n'est ce pas
heureusement je suis le seul à vous voir
et donc avec cette nouvelle contrainte
vous garder les mains collées et
maintenant vous regardez à droite et à
gauche est observée jusqu où est-ce que
ça va et observer ce qui se passe avec
vos coudes en fait dans cette position
vous coûte sont encouragés à aller à
droite et à gauche ça veut dire votre
poitrine ça veut dire qu'il ya une
partie différente de votre colonne qui
se met en route et on peut aller encore
plus loin pour révéler d'autres degré de
liberté
la même position mais cette fois on va
contraindre encore un petit peu plus on
va coller les coudes on va coller les
coudes contre la poitrine donc
contrainte encore plus importante est
maintenant si vous regardez à droite et
à gauche qu'est ce qui se passe
certaines personnes de début se sent
tellement complet contraintes qu'elles
vont faire juste ça et d'autres vont se
dire ah tiens qu'est ce qui se passe
avec mes genoux qu'est ce qui se passe
avec mon bassin rien dans la contrainte
ne dit qu'on n'a pas le droit de bouger
les jeunes ils passent mais voilà et le
miracle c'est qu'une fois qu'on a enlevé
les bras plus de contraindre maintenant
vous regardez à droite et à gauche
regarder jusqu'où est ce que vous pouvez
regarder peut-être même du voisin de
derrière
en tournant voilà donc vous en doutiez
peut-être mais votre intelligence pour
trouver des solutions comme ça est
fantastique
on est très apte à trouver des solutions
pour rendre les choses plus simples pour
rendre les choses plus économe plus
facile
on pourrait se dire comme tout à l'heure
je vais mettre plus de force
et puis rester avec ses habitudes ou
alors on pourrait se dire pour la même
action je vais étendre le champ de ce
que je sais faire et atteindre ce qui
m'intéresse avec plus de facilité donc
voilà ma proposition aujourd'hui ma
proposition c'est que peut-être quand
vous répète souvent qu'il faut sortir de
sa zone de confort mais moi je défends
que on pourrait quand on entend ça se
demander comment est ce qu'on peut faire
grandir cette zone de confort de manière
à inclure ce qui nous intéresse
oui ce n'est pas la même attitude
et puis si on veut être sur ce processus
l'un d'eux se dire tiens comment est ce
que je fait grandir ma zone de confort
bien ça s'appelle à prendre on a cette
faculté d'apprendre de nouvelles choses
de faire des expériences de concentrer
un petit peu ces expériences d'apprendre
de plus en plus et puis ce processus
nous emmène vers de plus en plus de
facilités parce qu'en fait c'est pas
simplement quelque chose qui est
impossible qui devient possible si on
continue le processus d'amélioration ce
qui était possible devient facile
agréable élégant donc vous voyez qu'on a
une gradation comme ça si je prends mon
exemple quand je vais nager forcément
des gens vont dire ouh la la qu'est-ce
qu'il est élégant dans sa nage en tant
que danseur ça ne fallait pas été
contacté par le ballet de lorraine
tessi qui l'ont pas mon numéro mais en
tout cas bon voilà je sais qu'il ya
quelqu'un du ballet j'aurais ici
peut-être que c'est l'occasion mais bon
jeu j'y compte pas trop
et entre les deux voiliers a des
compétences que je sais plus où moins
c'est plus ou moins facile pour moi
alors on se dit bon c'est bon
effectivement je vais progresser
tranquillement comme ça et tant de la
zone de confort mais il n'en reste pas
moins que ça peut paraître un petit peu
mou on se dit tiens
alors parce qu'il ya cette petite voix
qui dit mais j'ai quand même envie que
ça soit difficile à un moment on peut se
poser la question pourquoi pourquoi est
ce que j'ai envie que ça soit difficile
et là on revient à nos scénaristes
d'hollywood
parce qu'on se dit il rentre d histoire
haletante comment ça se fait comment ils
font un exemple personnel c'est que une
fois j'étais avec un ami
et puis avec son petit garçon de 5 ans
j'étais tout seul et puis il me dit est
ce que tu pourrais inventé une histoire
pour moi mon père le fait souvent
j'essaye et puis pour changer j'ai mis
une histoire où tout le monde était
gentil
c'était gentil au milieu gentil à la fin
je dis gentil au début tout le monde
était gentil je suis de mon histoire
très fier d'avoir été un peu disruptif
et puis il attend un peu qu'ils me
demandent avait fini ton histoire
si parmi elle est nulle
et là j'ai compris quelque chose que
dans les histoires justement dans les
scénarios les bons scénaristes forcément
il ya des drames viadeo il ya débat il
ya des moments où le serbe le héros est
perdu mais il trouve une solution
donc là il ya quelque chose d'émotionnel
il ya quelque chose qui dit comment est
ce qu'on dépasse quelques fins une la
nouveauté comment est-ce qu'on dépasse
l'adversité mais ça aussi ça se cultive
ça aussi c'est fait agrandir sa zone de
confort donc maintenant on peut se
tourner vers cette question comment est
ce que je fait grandir cette zone de
sécurité le confort la sécurité
l'apprentissage et si on se tourne vers
les gens qui s'intéressent au stress et
aux dangers à la réaction de l'organisme
face à ça traumatisme et c'est ce qu'ils
nous disent c'est que face à un danger
bah on est un peu comme un escargot qui
rentrait dans sa coquille dans certains
cas et un escargot dans sa coquille si
vous le prenez que vous le secouer il
sortira pas plus donc de quoi a besoin
escargot pour sortir il a besoin qu'on
le pose qu'ils se sentent un petit peu
en sécurité et puis ensuite il sort de
sa coquille progressivement ils
vérifient qu'il est en sécurité et
ensuite il remet en route sa faculté
d'aller explorer son petit bout de
jardin
maintenant je crois que vous avez
quelques éléments pour comprendre
pourquoi j'ai pris autant de plaisir
pendant cette course qualificative aux
jeux olympiques et je vous en souhaite
tout autant dans ce qui vous intéresse
[Applaudissements]